Gasper lost details about the rest all
right Thank You Agatha yes so I guess
those of you that were here for the last
session already saw a little bit about
data structures where a new coverage
some lower bounds prosthetic data
structures but this session we will be
talking about dynamic data structures so
just to make sure that everyone knows
where the Namek data structure is I
think most of you are probably computer
scientists and had some sort of
introduction to a Loomis course at some
point but maybe some are mathematicians
and don't know so the goal in dynamic
data structures and data structures is
to maintain some sort of database under
updates to the data and then you can
associate support asking queries to the
data okay so you have data set updates
inquiries they're just gonna give a
brief example of a data structure
problem that will also be proving low
bounce four so there's updates and
queries so this is something like a toy
data structure problem maybe use it as
subroutine in other data structures or
algorithms so this problem is called
prefix sums so here the data you're
maintaining in the data set is just an
array of n entries every array a has n
entries and initially this array is just
in this light all zeros and then you
have updates and queries to this array
and what an update does is that so an
update takes an index i from 0 to n
minus 1 and it takes a value Delta and
then the effect of the update is that
you add Delta to array entry I okay so
it's a simple operation and that's the
updates you need to support and the
queries will be considering here is a
prefix some query so let's just take U
of I so query is specified by an index
into the array as well the goal is to
return the prefix some meaning I sum
from n to 0 opt I have to read ok I'll
try out some other ones
that's why this one's okay so updates
and it's not much better okay it's a
delta to some index in the array and the
query is against this Python indexing
you have to sum all the numbers in this
prefix okay so for instance if you had
already made some of this this is 2 this
is 0 1 1 3 and 0 then the answer to this
query is supposed to be 7 now you add up
the numbers and return them so this is
sort of like a classic toy data
structure problem and what is the data
structure then if the data structure is
then some sort of representation in
memory of this object that allows you to
answer these queries and updates
efficiently no we can say it's positive
and negative what we'd be assuming here
is just it's some little bit integer so
let's so let's say Delta is in minus 2
to the L 2 may be off by one if you want
L bits but just some bound into LS say
so so in most settings when you
implement these data starts as you will
do it in a word Ram model so what's the
word Ram upper bounds the word Ram you
think of your computer as having a
memory the consist of random XS cell so
it's just a big array you can do random
access into and this array the memory
each cell has some W bits ok so I think
you've also mentioned this and one
common assumption when you work these
problems is for instance that L is less
than equal to W so that you can store
weight in and in a memory cell and
typically you also assume that W is say
at least log M so that a memory cell can
store pointer into the array given
homages if you work on a normal computer
you have 64-bit variable so you can stop
pointers to all your memory locations so
this is a common assumption in data
structure upper bounds
and each again mr. daga random access
memory and you think of the cells as
being indexed by integers and suppose in
place you will say that the last one
years people the W minus one so an
address of the memory cell also fits in
one word so a solution to this prefix
some problem is a very simple solution
of course right it depends on what is
your goal do we want to reduce the
update time as much as possible if you
want to reduce the query time as much as
possible you want to balance the things
the truth all right so in one extreme if
I want really fast updates then what I
do is so then my data structure is I
just thought the array as it is right so
whenever I get an update I need to add
something to this entry
I just do that but then the problem is
the query time becomes really slow
because if I need to compute the prefix
some I have to go through all these
entries and add them up
ok so so that's one solution where the
update time is constant but the query
time is linear so of course it's always
like question of how do you balance the
two and I think like at the point where
you balance these two terms the most the
best solution looks like this so if this
is your array that you're trying to
represent then you build a binary tree
on top of this array or you imagine that
there is some binary tree on top of the
array
- okay so we have a a binary tree and
you star for every node in this tree
including the leaves you store like a
variable in your memory and while you
start like for every node you store the
sum of all the array entries in the
subtree this make sense this
representation and so again if this was
2 0 1 1 3 this restore to just will
start to this Woodstock 4 and so on just
saw the sum of everything in the subtree
is it still hard to see the color this
representation if I need to update this
representation if I need to add Delta to
this node you see that this reputation
the only notice to change those on this
root to leaf path and you just need to
add Delta to all of them right so so you
just walk this path and add dill
tutorial variables and this takes the
login time and similarly if I need to
compute now the sum of this range what I
do is I traverse the tree down to the
leaf just after then you can convince
yourself if I take everything thats
hanging off to the left of this path and
sum it up then I get this sum here so
this is the root of the subtree thats
hanging off to the left and this is the
root of a structure that's hanging off
to the left if I just add up these two
numbers then they give a disjoint cover
of this range so they give me the sum if
I add these up so again it's long and
time in the query yes so let's in this
time and say T sub Q is the query time
and T sub U is the update time and
they're both auto-login in this solution
it's now going to prove lower bounds in
the rest of the talk and we will be
start up by proving lower bounds for
this for this problem here the prefix
some problem and I'll try to go through
the different techniques that have been
developed since people started looking
at dynamic data structure lower bounds
and I try to sit I think the proofs are
not identical as the original ones but
the technique is sort of the same it's
the same ideas just simplified I think
using what we know today so the first
technique I will go through is this one
by Friedman insects a back to I think
it's dark 1989 old technique the very
first one for proving dynamic Esther
kilo bounce it's known as the
chronograph technique so the idea is if
I want to prove a lower bound for this
problem I first define a hot
distribution of operations to this
problem so for this array problem the
hot distribution is going to look like
this so remain right so the data is this
length in the rain and what we have here
is that we'll have updates and this is
time order so we're going to perform
updates one by one at the very end we're
going to ask a query okay
so one of the updates look like so first
I'm going to do a batch of in updates
where I simply write a uniform random
value to each array entry like I add
that to every every entry so I here I do
array entries 0 I add some beautiful
random little bit number to that entry
the next operation is to array entry 1
add uniform random little bit value to
that entry and so on have n of these
next I'm going to do a batch of somewhat
fewer updates ok so I'm going to have
what we call an epoch of update so this
is one epoch of updates this is the next
epoch of updates and so on and the size
of these epochs go down geometrically so
the ithe epoch in this game has size
beta to the I for some parameter beta
will fix signal this is epic number log
based beta of in the next one is epic
log based beta n minus 1 and so on
ok so they go down the number of updates
go down by affected beta each time and
one of the updates look like in inside
the I epic well they're just it's just
the same as this one except that I
spaced them out in the array so it's
well the first epic updates every single
entry the ice epic updates every in or
beta to the is entry so so they look
like something like this
0 times every entry that Co times in all
beta to the I gets an update of Delta 0
the next one here 108 gets an update and
so on this makes sense so I just just go
to the array and space out my update
human being the array the locations a
deterministic in this setting that
deterministic yes I believe I have seen
your written proof it was not
deterministic but here is deterministic
space them out okay so that's my heart
sequence of updates and then at the very
end I'm going to ask a uniform random
query Q and Q just picture and array
entry now you need to compute the prefix
sum up to here so you just sum all these
values here this make sense so far
and beta is some parameter will fix this
it's more than two yes it's at least two
or something it would be if you want to
know it'll be proportional to the update
time yes this is yes oh yeah right is
there's one two three four and this is
log base Beethoven yes so so this is the
smallest epic yeah epic one consists of
just beta updates and then you go up
until you have in updates in the last
one so it paid us at least to this
sequence has off in operations in total
basis so now we get to sort of we have
we have to tough prove now that this
query has to read a lot of memory cells
that's what we hope to prove yes then
the the query time has to be high if we
do need a lot of memory cells okay so
let's try to prove that and here's where
the sort of the name chrono gram
technique comes from so their idea for
proving sub C lower bound is to look at
if I have a data structure D and I've
run this sequence of operations on it
okay that would produce some sort of
memory state make sense right so so the
memory state of the data structure if I
run it remember again in the data
structure it's just a bunch of memory
cells from 0 1 up to potentially 2 to
the W minus 1 each of them store some W
bits and if I run all these updates and
I look at my memory cell okay so some of
the updates some of the cells have been
have been changed so zolda sales have
been changed what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take all the cells that have
been updated and then I'm going to color
them based on which epoch that last the
the last epic that touched this cell
make sense so as I go through all my
updates when I when I'm finished with
the epic one perhaps all these cells
have been changed in memory then I go to
the second so this is the let's say the
black epic I'm going to get to the next
step hawk this is the green epic but the
data structure does is it starts to
write themselves perhaps it changes some
of the previous cells then we you
override the color and so on this make
sense
so I color the cells so a cell
see I if it's last updated
what's during epoch I just make sense so
the cells are now colored based on when
they were last changed by the data
structure
okay so now the idea is that we're going
to define a set of sails for every color
CI she justice it sails color I make
sense so far so we have a bunch of sets
all these sets at this joint
each cell is only associate to one of
these sets the one when was last updated
so the proof now proceeds as follows so
let me
so we're going to define sit
P of Q so the query is called Q the
random query so P of Q are just going to
define as the set of cells read by the
data structure D on query Q and this is
also a function of the set of updates
right so based on what the updates did
what you read might change and now the
whole proof boils down to the following
so we want to prove this there beta it's
large enough then it must be the case
that you expect the size of P of Q
intersect C I is for all I so what is
this saying it's saying that if my data
starts is correct and the size of these
epochs go down fast enough then when I
answer this uniform random query at the
end I have to read like it at least in
expectation at least one cell or half a
cell or something like that from each of
these epochs the expectation is over Q
you are also Delta's also over the
deltas yeah so this is expectation over
let's say that the updates that's called
the new or the updates that happened and
Q
so we do let's have some notation here
that we'll use so so let's have a random
variable that's you facebait up in for
the updates in the epic block-based bit
up in one and then we can use you to
denote all of them all the updates that
help and queues the random error giving
the query so first of all but so I
thought before we try to prove this we
can give some sort of intuition why this
has to be true why why would the correct
data start to have to read something
from every airport and there's a really
good reason for why so if you think
about it so here's epic I this updates
happening in there and the query is at a
random position so it's answer is going
to depend on what happened in here right
because it's the sum of all so some of
the updates that happened in epic I yeah
the data structure is just keeping doing
all the prefix sums right after every
update then the update time is going to
be very large right and Beta Beta is
going to depend on the update time line
this large enough is going to be
something depending on the update time
the lower bound on the query time comes
constant in in that case yeah okay so
the answer somehow depends on their poor
guy
and if we don't read if you assume for
contradiction that maybe there's a
solution that doesn't read from every
guy then somehow all the cells from
outside should tell us what we need to
know about these updates that make sense
that's an intuition ok so but now we can
try to look at so what about this these
sets Z log base beta Finn down to CI
plus 1 so everything that happened
everything that was written before I per
guy these things were written before you
did these updates
all right so and somehow they cannot
contain any information about these
updates right because you didn't know
what the updates were going to be when
you wrote these sits so somehow these
are useless if you want to know what if
a guy does to the query
that's what intuition and so then the
other intuition is why can the small
epics not help us all the ones in the
future well there the idea is that so if
the update time is really small then all
the things that they wrote it has to be
a small set of sales fight so in
particular if you look at an epic how
many cells can change how much can this
set CIP well if the worst-case update
time is tu there were beta to the AI
updates during up a guy each of them can
change tu cells and each of those cells
can have W bits okay so this is the size
in bits and so all the cells in a set
see I make up for dispute bits okay so
if you look at all the the epics you
look at all this these epics CI minus
one down to see one or the little epics
you want to come after the guy the total
size of their sets
it's going to be a beta to the I minus
one
- eww it makes us the biggest one of
them dominates this Sun because it goes
down to emit really fast
tell me says so so all the little sets
are so small this is much it less than
as so how many updates were than epic
either would beta to the I updates each
of them inserts an L bit random number
somehow if you want it was a good place
to write it make sense here entropy of
the updates that happened during epoch I
so the amount of information that's in
the / gaya is they were beta to the I
updates all riding in a bit number if
beta is sufficiently small then all this
information it's going to be less than
than this one does it make sense all the
information that's being written in all
the future epochs is so small that it
cannot really help you on epic I so
that's the intuition and let's try to
prove it formally maybe it'll be clear
if it's not clear yet how it's yourself
but that's the basic idea that
everything in happened before cannot
help you because it was in the past
everything that happened afterwards
there's just not enough time to write
the stuff you need to help you on these
queries that's the C intuition so
therefore you have to read something
from a poor guy
let's try to prove it formally yeah that
indeed this is the case and the way
we're going to prove it it's being an
encoding argument with somehow it seems
convenient for these lower bounds so
well consider is a game between an
encoder Ellis and a decoder Bob so this
game we're going to assume for
contradiction that this is false
okay so let's assume that just expect
the size here let's let's use some
Epsilon okay so what's the game that
we're looking at so Ellis sees all of
the updates as everything except if a
guy has everything else and the goal is
for Ellis to send Bob a message such
that Bob can recover all the updates of
the poor guy Mixon so that's the
communication you're just like an
encoding Ellis is trying to encode epoch
I and Bob needs to recover a poor guy
and the way we chose these updates were
independent between the different epochs
right it's just every single change we
did to an arranger was just add a random
value it ran the add a random L bit
value so this means that particular
the entropy of UI condition of
everything else is still beta to the I
times L bits if you stand on source
coding theorem to say that the if Bob
can always recover UI from Alice's
message then the expected length of it
Ellis's message has to be at least bail
to the I times L just like compression
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to say that if our data structure
doesn't read anything from a poor guy
then there's a way for Ellis to send a
very short message that still allows Bob
to recover UI and that gives the
contradiction and of course are going to
use the data starts you to to construct
this message so so what does Ellis do so
this is Alice's so L is just you know
runs all the updates you and collects
these sets you see log base pair of em
okay and now let's do a first attempt
then so this is the first thing she does
and then she sends all the little ones
to Bob
let's her message she just sends
everything that is updated during epochs
I - one down to one she sends those off
to Bob meaning the same follow these
cells yes yes since you know the address
of all the cells and the contents of all
these cells okay and so how many bits is
she sending well at most some of all
these epochs you know the size of CJ
yeah Lee before they do update time
something like this and for every cell
she sends W bits for the contents and
another W bits to specify the address so
again we said that the number of cells
that she changes this is not bits this
is a number of cells so you could only
change beta to the J times the update
time cells like this the update time is
to you and that's beta to the J updates
so the total number of things you can
change this beta to the J times to you
and the last term dominates so this is
beta to the I minus one to you that's
the number of things that this is the
size times the W this makes sense she
sense to go but it was before nothing's
much worth after this it just sends what
it is at the very end of everything when
you get to the very end she just sends
this is the contents at the very end
okay when I'm done with when I'm done
with everything the cell has this punch
just telling get something Bob what it
looks like just before this query Q is
about to happen
so here this is where we're using this
geometric decay in the size of the epics
because this is small it might be small
compared to
so I think a normal assumption is that
the what will be assuming now just for
simplicity is that L is theta W so let's
say it's analog in just two I think this
is the most natural case to consider
like the updates are pre normally
bounded introduce an M and the word size
is also theta log n so you can store
these this is the most common setting of
parameters and just to simplify things
here guess then this is also data to the
islands one
if w Anila within constant factors at
each other so that's the size of the
message and you can see here if beta is
large enough this is going to be smaller
than the entropy of UI that makes sense
how do you get do you attend to W then
well it's not this way okay so there is
so in epic J there's beta to the J
updates happening the update time is to
use each of them can change tu cells and
each cell has W bits that's how it goes
okay so this message is going to be
short if we said beta big enough it's
going to be much shorter than that make
sense through particular if beta is say
10 to you then this is going to be like
a small constant factor of the entropy
so the missus is short so far but now we
of course we want to argue that this
message allows Bob to recover UI but
otherwise we're not done yet we're just
actually that the session should end
this way 3f we got a good
it's
so okay so we're going to see what can
Bob do now based on this message and are
completely done yet we'll change that a
little bit but let's just see what
happens
what's popular Bob has its remember Bob
received everything except epic I since
so far obviously on the time axis here
Bob knows all the big epics that precede
up a guy it has this unknown chunk of
updates and then he knows the little
ones as well right so when Bob does is
that okay so he knows everything that
happened before so he just runs the day
to start you up to this point and
constructs the memory as it was at this
point in time so Bob now has the memory
he knows what it looked like at this
point in time just before this happened
and now what he does is so from Alice's
message he also knows everything that's
changed during doing these epochs over
here
you knows everything that's changed here
so what he does is that he first months
they start to up to here and then he
updates the contents of the memory cells
that Ellis message tells him that has
changed that make sense so that means
that Bob's idea of what the memory is is
correct except in CI that makes it
everything is correct as it is over here
except for those in CI that I listed not
seem to him and then it doesn't know
everything right except CI so so what
could can Bob do now
so intuitively you look at our
assumption up here most of the queries
that you can ask I'm not going to read
anything from CI that make sense
this is him something's only going to be
an epsilon fraction of the queries that
will be anything from CI so so therefore
what Bob does is just he he runs
supports decoding procedures just run
all queries q assuming this is the
correct memory this runs all the queries
and whenever reads the cell and just use
this contents here for some of the
queries it will be wrong because it
actually read something from CI and you
didn't hurt you didn't have the right
contents of that cell but for most
queries it will be correct and that
means not from what we've sent so far at
least because you only have the changes
that happened afterwards yet so you
don't know you can't detect that this
happened so in some sense this means
that Bob will answer Bob fails on only
stupid hand wavy on only epsilon n
queries
that's only if so infection that reads
anything what happens during the if
nothing [ __ ] after all I can depend on
what would sell sir change during yes
yeah but the point is no but that's what
and it's since you're so simple this is
not you I you I might want to you one
it's not the updates it's the changes
that they make in memory
yes that's yeah that's crucial it's the
so Ellis tells Bob the changes in the
memory
well already knows what the updates are
yeah so that's that's a crucial point so
Bob actually he fails only on epsilon n
queries and is correct on the rest of
the queries so now Bob wants to try to
recover all these changes that happen
during epoch I do you think about it so
Bob okay so Bob has this query that he
has some I guess on what is the answer
he thinks it's correct so he knows all
the updates except those in epic eye
which means that he can subtract off the
contributions to sum from everything
outside of a guy does that make sense
because he knows all the other updates
so that leaves him with just some of the
green ones
it has just the some of those that were
updated in Africa and so now what Park
does is if you look at the memory right
there's these chunks in between each of
the updates and it just takes a majority
Boden on all the answers that he thinks
are correct here that makes sense we
just looked I have all these queries the
spacing here is a no-brainer to the eye
so I just take these annual beta to the
eye a look at what is the most popular
answer to the queries and that is my
guess for this entire prefix um now of
course this majority can only be wrong
if more than half of these answers are
wrong that make sense we know only
epsilon in fail so it's going to be only
something like a two epsilon fraction of
all the blocks that can be wrong so he
would be correct on by far the majority
of blocks that make sense there's so few
queries that fail and you need half of
all the entries to to fail in order to
get a wrong guess by Bob so he would be
correct on all but some the two epsilon
fraction of the blocks
and if you want to finish up because you
didn't formally recover UI yet
so what Ellis can do the last step of
her message is just so Ellis knows
exactly what Bob's going to do what Bob
is just want to run all the queries
ladies can also do that before she sends
a message and figure out which majority
votes will fail just press it and then
she just in addition to this she just
sends Bob the corrections just says oh
these votes are going to be wrong and
this is the correct answer
and so how much does that take so it's
only something like an epsilon fraction
of the blocks that are going to fail and
there's beta to the ID blocks and each
of them the right answer has L bits so
make sense so she's just going to send
all the corrections to Bob and now Bob
you know first one solve the queries do
all the majority votes and then fix the
few mistakes that that were made and
then pop actually recovers to UI
so what Bob has is the correct prefix
sum up to here the correct prefix time
up to there the correct prefix time up
to there the create prefix sum up to
here so the first one just tells him the
first answer
now if you need to get out what this
update value was it just attracts off
this one and then you get that value
this sometimes that sum is this value
again this sum - that some gives you
that value so Bob can learn all the
values you just avoid the last and say
that work output it and it's sort of
like as a lot of information about UI
that it did self yeah you could also
yeah you could also do that this is just
to strictly adhere to this encoding game
but yes there's already a lot of
information it's too much compared to
the length of the message right
depending on how comfortable you are
with amount of information but yes the
last step is not really needed but
there's already tons of information and
this correction just shows some way of
showing that there's a lot of
information
okay so that's the chrono Graham
technique and okay so let's see why when
do we get a lower bound when we have a
contradiction where we have a
contradiction if if this Plus that is
less than beta to the I times L right
because then we compressed you I to
listen than the entropy if you look at
it Epsilon there's a peel that's our
print ridiculous assumption there's some
small epsilon such that you only be very
few cells the other one here if so I
want to set beta large enough so that
this is much smaller than here so we
talked about before that if I said beta
to something like 10 to you and this is
going to be much smaller than the
entropy then this has to be at least the
entropy the rest so we get a
contradiction because both this is much
smaller and this is much smaller and our
assumption was
so this is wrong and and we have our
conclusion so that was the the original
technique here and so now let me go
fifteen years ahead okay so what kind of
noble do we get right so so our yes
sorry okay so we just prove this claim
here right so that particular is beta is
larger than ten to you let's say then
the expected size at the intersection
between the set of cells red and if a
guy is Omega 1 and why does that give
our lower bound so so thus it's C want
to see log base beta then are all
disjoint so of course the size of Q has
to be at least several Y of the size of
intersection make sense right because
these sets are disjoint and now just
take expectation on both sides of the
narrative expectation is the expected
number of probes is at least some World
War I the expectation of this was Omega
one
and how many terms out of this log base
paid up in so get this lower bound and
beta was ten to you or base to you a bit
so the time and this was the expected
time to the experience query time
expected query time this Omega love
based the update time of in and so this
also explains what you're saying before
what what if during pre-processing you
spend a lot of time you know
pre-computing recomputing all the prefix
sums using linear time and you see that
the lower bound and the query time
becomes constant make sense so if you
care about you know how strong is this
lower bound you can try things to what
is the maximum of the query time in the
update time and if you look at a little
while you realize it let's peek set log
n over log login that's there if you set
the update time to log in or log log n
then the log of the query time is also
locking all are looking no you cannot
you yeah you can actually you can okay
so just a few words you can also prove
this lower bounds if L is just one okay
so the number of bits you just set a bit
there it's actually tight you just did
submit but if you have the number of
bits in an update or theta W then it's
not tight the log in solution before
it's actually tied and that's the next
thing I'll show you
it's official you thought so when you
say like a constant question so Bob
fields in it yeah okay so I did here you
need yeah I cheated a little bit
you need to create a veto of it does it
just back up a little bit it's it's
fairly easy you just say for for half of
all the use the expected credit times
most affected to latter over a random
queue and then you only do encoding some
that half of all the object sequences
and then the the entropy it is entropy
here is the same minus one bit something
like that so you just look at all the
update sequences were conditioned on
seeing this update sequin the expected
query time is still what it was before
so the expected query time only goes up
by a factor two for half of all the
securing up what the problem is so so I
cheat a little bit by saying he fails
only on this many queries for some of
the sequences you will fail on more
queries you know once in a while maybe
you fail on all the queries but you can
handle that by saying you know my
markups only half of all the update
sequences has the expected query time
afterwards that's affect to more than
the original expected query time and
then you can just encode only those
sequences and you loose only one bitten
in the end it's up for me a change with
I let's know that's no problem no yeah
yes okay that's just taking us to to not
have too many details so I think I try
to sketch the next technique that sort
of actually prove the tied lower bound
for this problem and so this is due to
Petrus Cohen domain 2004 so took 15
years before the next higher lower bound
was proved
so this technique is known as the
information transfer it's going to be
easier to describe now that we have all
of the sum of all this terminology it's
the same problem that we're considering
still this prefix sums but we have a
different way of analyzing instead of
having these epochs so what we do now is
we can have like a hot sequence of
updates but this time we're going to mix
the updates with queries so we have
queries and updates and mixed with each
other and what's going to look like so
now I just you know
so the first update is going to it's
going to be a little strange I'll try to
motivate why are you going to take an
index in the array and update it like
before and now so what do I mean by for
this arrow here so the index that I'm
going to update is going to be if I take
I write it in binary and then I reverse
the bits so this is called a bit
reversal permutation
so sometimes the person thinks I'm going
to do is zero so let's log in bits zero
reverse is just 0 and the next entry I'm
going to update is going to be one end
and a random number again so this is
going to be entry so it just reversed
the bits of the index and the reason why
I do this is just that this will see a
little bit later the only motivation is
that this spreads out the locations like
before it just spreads out where you
update that's the only reason and this
one is just convenient for the arguments
later on so just think of it like before
you just try to spread them out and this
is one way of doing it and again we just
add random L bit values no yeah so now
we just have one long sequence of in so
there's no epics anymore so n minus 1 in
the reverse that's the updates that
we're going to perform and we go and I
said we're going to mix them with
queries updates here this is the
sequence and actually what we're going
to do is just right after we did an
update we're going to do a query at the
same index so so this is also 0 in
Reverse and this is going to be 1 in
Reverse and make sense the sequence so
update intra-syrian reverse with a some
random number query the prefix sum up to
that point of data entry 1 reversed
query the prefix up to that point and so
on just still guess the seats
and now we're going to try to analyze it
again to prove it all about
so what we do here is you have the
sequence of operations and we're going
to consider a binary tree on top of this
sequence so these are the queries these
green ones are the queries the blue ones
and the updates we build a binary tree
on top of the sequence to say this
there's a need for every consecutive
pair and so on have this binary tree to
call the information transfer tree and
like before in the chronograph technique
we call out all the the cells based on
last time they were updated in this
technique instead we're going to if we
have a data structure and we run this
sequence of updates again this is time
run the sequence of updates on the data
structure and we're going to look at all
the cell probe or the probes it makes
into memory all the reads yeah the
position is not meant no it's the same
so it's several reversed again one
reverse to reverse those a fixed
sequence again okay so what we do is we
run the data structure we look at so the
data start your wallet process is this
sequence it has its memory and maybe
when I get to to this update operation I
make some probes into memory some
lookups okay so maybe let's say this
read it has a bunch of probes it's
called a Pima you want to pick a each
probe is reach the cell of writes to a
cell okay so maybe this one reads this
memory cell this one which this memory
so maybe this one meter
you're going to take the probes and then
we're going to assign them to nodes in
the tree in a clever way so what we do
is so how do we assign this probe we
look at the cell it reads it has
addressed a cell number a we go back in
time and look at when was the last time
that a was also probed ago here when in
the witness Lee the last time that a was
also probe maybe this query over here
also had a probe that read entry a said
mix-ins so find the last time that this
happened so this has also some c1 yes I
don't know and this cell also this this
probe was altered to sell a then I'm
going to take my propia and I'm going to
assign it to the lowest common ancestor
of this probe in that probe so this one
is sitting here this one was sitting
there so go up the tree and find the
lowest common ancestor and then I'm
going to take this probe and put it here
so all the probes that my data structure
does is assigned to it and noting the
tree some of them I actually not even
assigned if I read something that was
never probe before I don't even assign
it some perceptive probes have been put
in the street and then we're going to
define so this is a node B then we're
going to define a set P of B is the set
of probes assigned to
so this tree is being populated by a
bunch of probes into memory and now what
we will try to prove is that every node
in this tree must have a lot of probes
assigned to it so that's the goal what
we claim the tree we expect the size of
so the expected number of probes
assigned to B has to be proportional to
a node over 2 to the depth of me and and
this is assuming W just makes sense
so what I'm claiming is that I have my
binary tree if you think about me to go
up to the root and the total number of
operations in the sub trees M if I go
these steps down to this one has maybe
50 from the roof then this n over 2 to
the D operations in this sub tree maybe
plus minus 1 it all to 2d trust 1 maybe
ok so what I'm saying is or what I'm
claiming is that if I look at a node the
expected size of this set is
proportional to the number of operations
in the sub tree the basis
or to the number of operations in the
subtree now I wanna say that if I can
prove this then we get the lower bound
we're after this why is that so again
any probe in this sequence is assigned
to at most one node in the tree so then
we conclude that the total number memory
probes it has to be at least the sum
over all nodes in the tree the size of
PV assigns with most one node
now take expectation on both sides
expected number of probes and you have
expectation move it in I keep going to
split the sum first into the sum over
all the depth from zero to sum over all
the nodes and T sub set the depth of VSD
and then do like this sensor 1 what I
did this we replace by n over 2 to the D
how many nodes either of depth D this 2
to the D notes so all of this transform
again
let's login terms so the total
processing time is Omega n log n and
there were in operation so of course the
the cost of an operation has to be Omega
log in amortized cost does that make
sense so the rights that we have so what
we know now is we have in updates plus
inquiries and so this sum has to be
Omega in the log in so that sickly the
max of tu and GQ has to be Omega log in
and so this is the tied lower bound is
we saw before right we had the solution
that had log in on both of them
because they were in this sequence and
we consider there were n updates and
they have to you time each there's the
update time and you have n queries that
have TQ time each so each one is
represented in a different day sir no
updates there being no both no both
queries and updates I'm having the
probes assigned to the tree yeah I guess
yeah yeah yeah possibly different
locations could be all over but every
single probe that's being made in the
entire sequence is assigned in this tree
and yes before we try to prove that it's
very good time to do the break now so
let's have the break now and continue
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]